aujourd'hui pour le calendrier de
l'avent de tv78 je vous propose non pas
du chocolat mais une spécialité salée et
100 % ivelinoise le pâté de
[Musique]
Houdan attention on ne rigole pas avec
ce produit misise au point au 19e siècle
par Victor Tasserie il a ses codes de
fabrication défendu par une confrerie
gastronomique le pâté de Houdan c'est
avant tout un pâté en croûte à base de
poule de Houdan une volaille ancienne à
crête sa farce est également composée
d'une mousse de foie de volaille et
d'une duxelle de champignon le tout dans
une pâte brisée cette spécialité
traditionnelle a même son propre
concours annuel qui récompense les
meilleures productions en somme le pâté
de houdans c'est un met idéal à mettre
sur votre table pour les fête de fin
d'année vous pouvez l'acheter dans
plusieurs enseignes oudanais tels que la
boucherie des arts ou encore fromage et
saveurs mais aussi dans des restaurants
comme la poularde ou tout simplement sur
le marché de Houdan tous les vendredis
matin